Movie sets must be the perfect workplaces
for screw-ups and joking around.
As gag reels have shown us, it doesn't matter
what kind of movie the actors are working
on.
Whether it's a low-rent comedy or an Oscar-winning
epic, sometimes the actors just can't keep
a straight face when they're supposed to be
taking things much more seriously.
Chop, chop
Liam Neeson definitely has "a special set
of skills," but in real life, it's not being
good at killing people — it's acting well.
In films like Schindler's List and Rob Roy,
Neeson showed that he's a serious actor who
doesn't meet his roles halfway.
Except on the set of The A-Team, where it's
pretty clear that Neeson's "special set of
skills" doesn't include being able to say
the words "attack choppers."
"There's two attack chopters…
"Hahahaha."
"Pike buys out every seat on the train.
There's two attack choppers..
F--- it."
A crowded elevator
Oscar-winner Philip Seymour Hoffman, Oscar
nominees Joaquin Phoenix and Amy Adams, and
Emmy-winner Rami Malek step into an elevator.
It sounds like the setup to a joke, but it's
just another day on the set of Paul Thomas
Anderson's The Master — a serious movie
about serious things.
And then...
"(Fart sound)"
It's the one thing you're never supposed to
do, especially around Oscar winners.
But to everyone's credit, they found it pretty
funny.
Well, everyone except Joaquin Phoenix.
Joaquin Phoenix does not laugh if the script
does not tell Joaquin Phoenix to laugh.
Burning sensation
Harvard-educated, Oscar-winning actress Natalie
Portman took on a rare comedic role in the
2010 spoof Your Highness , a movie with some
pretty ridiculous moments.
"I don't want to think about that."
"Let's just say that we were moments late
and he was able to… get her cookies."
"Shut up."
Portman gave the film's silly dialogue her
all, but there's one line she had a really
hard time getting through.
"I know the feeling well.
It's been burning in my beaver since… (hahah)"
"It's been burning in my bh-ah..."
At least she tried!
There will be bloopers
Daniel Day-Lewis has won three Oscars for
Best Actor in a Leading Role, which is more
than anyone else in history.
He obviously puts a lot of work into his performances,
to the point of staying in character even
when the cameras aren't rolling.
Day-Lewis doesn't even break character between
takes…and yet here he is, during There Will
Be Blood, cracking up with the actor who plays
his son after a take.
He's human after all.
Pug power play
1997's sci-fi comedy Men In Black sees odd
couple special agents played by Tommy Lee
Jones and Will Smith take on a whole galaxy
of alien oddities.
One of their toughest foes comes in the form
of a pug.
To get information out of it, Jones' Agent
K has to shake the crap out of it.
The thing is, that was a real dog, so Tommy
Lee Jones had to actually shake it and actually
demand information...from a little dog in
his hands.
"Rosenberg said something about a galaxy on
Orion's belt what's he talking about Frank?"
"Beats me?"
"Beats you?"
"Rolf rolf oh no oh oh"
It must have been a ridiculous scene to film,
because even in the final cut, you can see
Tommy Lee Jones start to smile once before
the camera cuts.
Hand in glove
One of the funniest moments in Kubrick's 1964
Cold War satire Dr. Strangelove or: How I
Learned to Stop Worrying and Love the Bomb
finds the former Nazi scientist Dr. Strangelove—played
by the incomparable Peter Sellers—struggling
to control his own arm.
"Combined with a spirit of bored curiosity
for the adventure ahead..
Ha!"
Although Sellers never breaks character, Peter
Bull, standing to his left in the shot, can't
quite keep it together during the off-the-wall
performance.
And, really, can you blame him?
Acting suspect
The infamous lineup sequence in The Usual
Suspects was supposed to be a lot more serious.
Unfortunately, the cast wouldn't play ball.
According to Kevin Pollak, they just couldn't
take the line seriously.
And according to Gabriel Byrne, Benicio Del
Toro would not stop farting.
Eventually, director Bryan Singer gave up,
took a few different takes, and spliced them
together.
And a classic scene was born.
(laughter)
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!